yeah welcome to this new blood scam c4
yep always had a soft spot for this b6
move they can lead to too tricky play
the English Defence very often that
leads to a twins Indian type of
positions of course yeah yeah Black has
got an interesting idea let's see if he
plays Bishop d2 yep I can take here here
and then play d5 the ideas that black
tries to make sure that there's a pawn
on d4 that it's not defended let's say
the point is not on c3 like defending
the porn this is a default phone it's
potentially week and black and a Tekkit
with 96 95 and he's got a light squared
Bishop which is not a bad thing but this
Bishop is not able to defend the pawn
it's an interesting line not sure how
good it really is but its own an
interesting way to two very hmm yeah the
question is a forever am able to to
really do this put the put pressure on
the pollen or is this I mean knight c6 I
don't know it doesn't look like very
harmonious setup maybe I should rather
play c6 get the knight to f6 or
something at night at five later mm yeah
i actually prefer that
96 I don't know it looks very loose
after see takes d5 especially he's got
some pressure on d5 then I mean if I get
the live i have the knight on c6 on d5
are simply am much weaker here I have
fun d5 very safely protected and i still
have ideas of night f 54 influences
maybe i can he go here and also
intending be 5 p-5 can be a good idea
he's maybe trying to play G for this is
so this is an interesting move gaining
space and interesting I mean really
interesting not like interesting as in
this is an interesting picture picture
and you really mean this is a bad
picture I don't get what you're doing
h3g for something you can who you can
really do yeah should I play h5 and then
I'm not sure hmm h5 should I play age 5
ok securing f5 what the Good Knight to
f5 and make sure that it's not kicked by
G for my th Knight to f5 really put some
pressure on the dip on now I think I'm
actually threatening to take on c4
yep so he dropped back yeah I need to
okay but I have night each for him so
g4s not really move in this particular
situation and this is this this is the
idea to get the Queen to b4 or a 3
trying to harass them when this happen
the Queen now isn't doing so much anyway
and maybe I can also just play c5 and
and open it up him it could could be
good yeah maybe it's not a bad idea I
don't don't really know I don't like
this Queen opposed the rock but this of
course is so true for c5 as well it
takes I can take with the Queen it's
just a good position isn't it if it
takes on d5 I take on addy for attacking
the Queen yeah Queen takes I thought
rook takes I'm probably going in some
other pins
just intend to take c4 no not sure what
he is doing about that g4s not on do
2nite h form and it looks am very shaky
and this is really a bit polite even
probably at g4s an instant loss somehow
check kim's III map okay you won't play
that chief already looks insane yeah but
what what is he playing actually no this
guy's actually international master i
didn't really look at the name I just
just played the game didn't really look
at who I was playing okay yeah that's D
for now or they will deform what just
takes you four why not just take it and
it's probably yeah it's probably better
in some way not sure how much better but
it's it's it's very nice ok Knight d4 no
I know probably not
mm-hmm and there's many many things
hanging in this position thought night
maybe night here actually attacking
seaforth yeah this is probably good and
there's also night efore ideas attacking
the Queen and on f2 yeah let's go to the
side it was a pin but now I'm very often
on on c4 and they're still 90 for coming
okay
I can it's not something better probably
not take it it's just a pawn they don't
see any big gap big counter play I take
with the rook yeah he will invade and
having an a passer cannot be too bad
might be five yeah cavitus and Ruby to
as the possible news night a four-seam
planning that possible
yeah so make this mobile phone
9075 Totec the poem I need to I need the
King without the King has no way to to
do that no it was pretty good strategic
game maybe at least I don't think that
white had had any sort of her big active
possibilities here it's just a matter
how how um yeah or what what slightly
worse position you defend something not
a good position for the special the zone
it's a bit one-sided cannot really do
much yeah yeah look pretty good this
line is some an interesting way to play
I think maybe I'm white needs to take on
d5 early trying to learn clarifying this
position in the center it is okay i
think for black to play it's not an edge
or something but you can you can do it
it's speedy unclear yeah thanks for
watching